while we're busy gathering supplies  thanks to your help the public education  foundation also lending a hand to valley  teachers today the grand opening of the  foundation's teacher superstore it  provides supplies to help reduce  teachers out of pocket costs today for  twenty six dollars educators receive  roughly five hundred dollars worth of  items  i think one bonus to the store too is  that teachers get to come in and pick  what works for them and for their  classrooms so of course we have paper  and pencils and the things that teachers  tell us they need the most but we also  have some curriculum games and other  things that they can use to  individualize their class classroom for  their needs  if you would like to learn more about  pef's work to help valley teachers we do  have a link on our website and you can  even adopt a valley teacher or school to  help fund their school supplies